Una pregunta, ¿De qué marca es vuestro teléfono
móvil?
Supongo que muchos de vosotros, tal vez la
mayoría, responderéis que Apple, Samsung
o Huawei.
¿Cómo lo sé? Pues no, no se trata de ningún
truco de magia ni nada por el estilo.
Simplemente lo sé porque año tras año estas
tres empresas lideran las ventas en el mercado
mundial de teléfonos móviles. Entre las
3 venden aproximadamente la mitad de todos
los smartphones que se venden en el mundo.
(Hablamos de un mercado gigantesco. Se calcula
que en 2018 el número de usuarios de smartphones
alcanzó la brutal cifra de 3.000 millones
de personas.
China encabeza la lista de más usuarios a
nivel mundial, casi 780 millones de chinos
utilizan en su día a día un smartphone.
Y no solo eso. El gigante chino también se
ha convertido en un actor fundamental en la
industria. Por ejemplo, es el país de origen
de alguno de los mayores fabricantes de smartphones
de todo el planeta. Hablamos de empresas como
Huawei y ZTE.)
Pues bien, ¿Sabéis dónde se fabrican estos
dispositivos? Exacto, en la ciudad de Shenzhen,
más conocida como el Silicon Valley chino.
Os hemos hablado ya de este increíble lugar
en varios vídeos. Y si estás suscrito a
VisualPolitik no hará falta que te recuerde
que en apenas 40 años, Shenzhen pasó de
ser una pequeña localidad pesquera a convertirse
en una megaurbe especializada en la alta tecnología.
En uno de los lugares que más crecen de todo
el planeta.
[De todas formas por si acaso sois nuevos
por aquí, en la descripción os dejo el enlace
a varios vídeos]
(Y, ojo, no solo se trata de empresas como
Huawei o ZTE, las propias Apple o Samsung
trabajan con un montón de proveedores de
esta ciudad.
Es decir, prácticamente todos nosotros, de
una forma u otra estamos relacionados con
Shenzhen. Utilizamos los productos de esta
ciudad constantemente, todos los días y a
todas horas.)
En otras palabras ¡Todos tenemos un poco
de Shenzhen en nuestras manos!
Ahora bien, exactamente ¿cómo se produjo
esta enorme transformación? ¿Es un caso
único en el mundo? Y la pregunta más importante,
¿Qué diantres tiene que ver Shenzhen con
Honduras, uno de los países más pobres de
América e incluso del mundo.
Atentos.
(LA SEMILLA DEL CAMBIO)
Os lo contamos aquí en VisualPolitik, a comienzos
de los años 80, el entonces presidente chino,
Deng Xiaoping creó una “Zona Económica
Especial” en la frontera con Hong Kong,
Shenzhen.
Fue la primera de muchas que más tarde se
abrirían a lo largo y ancho de toda China.
Ahora bien, un momento, hay una pregunta que
seguros muchos os estáis haciendo: ¿qué
es exactamente una Zona Económica Especial?
Pues, amigos, básicamente una Zona Económica
Especial es un área geográfica delimitada
dentro de un país donde las normas para hacer
negocios son diferentes, por lo general mucho
menos restrictivas que las del resto del país.
(Las Zonas Económicas Especiales se diseñaron
como una forma de impulsar el comercio y la
inversión.
Tienen límites geográficos claros; normas
y regulaciones diferentes; un sistema administrativo
propio. En definitiva, hablamos de territorios
completamente orientados a los negocios, la
producción y la inversión.
Por así decirlo, en el caso de China, estos
lugares se convirtieron en una especie de
refugios capitalistas en pleno modelo socialista.)
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Fueron un enorme éxito.
La apertura de estas zonas económicas atrajo
un enorme volumen de inversión, tanto de
capital chino como extranjero.
Toda esa inversión atrajo a miles de inmigrantes
e impulsó la construcción de fábricas y
viviendas. Para mediados de la década de
los 90, Shenzhen ya tenía 3 millones de habitantes
y una economía extraordinariamente dinámica.
(Y el proceso continuó hasta nuestros días.
En la actualidad Shenzhen cuenta con 12 millones
de residentes, que suben a 15 millones durante
la temporada de verano y otoño cuando las
fábricas trabajan a destajo para atender
la demanda de regalos electrónicos en Navidad.
Santa Claus, amigos, no puede olvidarse de
los smartphones, los drones y todos los cachibaches
de última generación que durante las navidades
se entregan como si no hubiera mañana)
Ahora bien, ni mucho menos China ha sido el
único país en apostar por este modelo.
(Otro ejemplo de libro lo podemos encontrar
en los Emiratos Árabes Unidos, especialmente
en el Emirato de Dubái. [Seguro que lo sabéis
porque, también os lo hemos contado en varias
ocasiones en este canal.]
Hablamos por ejemplo de Jebel Ali o del Centro
Financiero de Dubái. Este último, no solo
tiene sus propias regulaciones sino que incluso
cuenta con sus propios tribunales.
Además, por supuesto, de poca burocracia,
pocos impuestos, mucha seguridad jurídica
y procedimientos sencillos para hacer negocios.)
[¿Qué más se puede pedir?]
Amigos, el caso es que la estrategia para
diversificar la economía más allá del petróleo
se basó fundamentalmente en estas Zonas Económicas
Especiales, que hoy suman más de 45 en todo
el país.
¿El resultado? Consiguieron que los Emiratos
tuvieran desde 1980 el mayor crecimiento económico
de toda la región. Durante este tiempo su
PIB se ha multiplicado ni más ni menos que
por 10.
Ahora bien, un momento. ¿Quiere decir esto
que por el mero hecho de abrir Zonas Económicas
Especiales el éxito está asegurado?
Pues, amigos, ni muchísimo menos. Para que
una Zona Económica Especial realmente funcione
tiene que cumplir con algunos requisitos:
Gestionarse con plena autonomía; tener buenas
infraestructuras; mucha seguridad jurídica;
mucha libertad económica; impuestos comedidos,
poca burocracia y terreno suficiente para
crecer.
Hasta el momento hemos visto 2 casos de éxito:
China y Emiratos.
Pero, ¿podemos encontrar alguno caso de fracaso?
Pues sí. En cierto modo la India ha sido,
históricamente, un ejemplo a no seguir.
Vereis, me explico. La India estableció sus
primeras zonas económicas especiales ni más
ni menos que en la década de los 60, por
tanto mucho antes que China. De hecho podría
ser considerada una pionera en todo este tema.
Sin embargo, en el año 2000 apenas había
7 zonas operando en todo el país con un resultado
mucho, muchísimo más discretos que los del
ejemplo chino, ¿Por qué?
Pues porque, amigos, estas zonas no eliminaban
la burocracia, no funcionaban con autonomía,
estaban muy limitadas en cuanto a espacio
y operaban con muchas, muchísimas restricciones.
[Vamos que más que Zonas Económicas Especiales
eran una auténtica castaña. Creo que ahora
podemos entender mejor porque China ha crecido
mucho más que la India durante las últimas
décadas].
Ahora bien, un momento. Llegados a este punto
creo que hay una pregunta que muchos os estáis
haciendo: Enrique, ¿qué diantres tiene que
ver todo esto con Honduras?
Pues… atentos.
(EL EXPERIMENTO HONDUREÑO, ¿REALIDAD O FICCIÓN?)
Amigos, las Zonas Económicas Especiales son
muy populares en el mundo del comercio internacional.
Desde los 80 su número ha crecido como la
espuma.
Si en 1986, la Organización Internacional
del Trabajo reportaba 176 zonas en 47 países,
en 2006 ya eran más de 3.500 en 130 países.
Actualmente en Latinoamérica se estima que
hay más de 300 Zonas Económicas Especiales.
Más de la mitad se encuentran en centroamérica.
Claro que, como os podéis imaginar con unas
condiciones mucho más limitadas que en el
caso Chino.
[Ya sabéis, a los gobiernos latinos les encanta
controlar todo… o al menos intentarlo]
Sin embargo, amigos, hay un país que ha puesto
sobre la mesa un plan para aparentemente cambiar
esta situación. Ese país es Honduras.
(Honduras es uno de los países más pobres
de toda la región.
Un país donde la inmensa mayor parte de la
población vive en condiciones de pobreza,
que tiene tasas de violencia enormes y donde
cada año decenas y decenas de miles de personas
intentan escapar en busca de una vida mejor,
generalmente dirigiéndose a los Estados Unidos.)
("Tengo que intentarlo": una nueva caravana
de migrantes sale de Honduras y se dirige
a los Estados Unidos. Washington Post.)
(Violencia y pandillas oscurecen la vida en
Honduras. America Economía)
Pues amigos… Durante los últimos años
Honduras ha presentado un ingeniosa estrategia
para darle la vuelta a esta situación.
Un plan en el que ha jugado un papel destacado
el economista estadounidense Paul Romer, Premio
Nobel de Economía en 2018.
La estrategia consiste en crear a lo largo
y ancho de todo el país las conocidas como
“Zonas de Empleo y Desarrollo Económico”
Ahora bien, ¿Qué son exactamente estas ZEDE?
Pues amigos, en la misma línea de lo que
os hemos contado, cómo en Honduras las cosas
no funcionan, las ZEDE son un especie de experimento
para que la actividad económica pueda empezar
a crecer desde cero en algunas zonas del país.
(Es decir, las ZEDE serán zonas del territorio
nacional hondureño que contarán con una
regulación especial e instituciones propias
que garanticen la seguridad - tanto física
como jurídica - y la facilidad para hacer
negocios.
Cómo todo empezaría desde cero, no haría
falta cambiar de golpe todo el sistema nacional,
algo que se antoja por todos los intereses
existentes como una misión imposible.
La idea es que estas ZEDE consigan atraer
mucha inversión y crear muchísimos empleos,
de tal forma que logren ser un revulsivo para
el resto del país. Tal y como ocurrió con
las Zonas Económicas Especiales de China.)
Las ZEDE tendrían personalidad jurídica
propia, se administrarían de forma autónoma
y estarían autorizadas a establecer sus propias
políticas y normativas.
Y no solo eso. También contarían con su
propia policía, sus propios tribunales independientes
e incluso operarían bajo la tradición del
derecho anglosajón, lo que se conoce como
la “common law”.
Además, amigos, la propiedad del suelo de
en estas zonas sería propiedad del estado,
pero su administración correría a cargo
de las propias ZEDE que establecerían claramente
el método o los pasos a seguir para acceder
y desarrollar ese suelo.
Todo en un marco de competencia para que las
empresas y los inversores cuenten con el suelo
necesario para sus proyectos y no se enfrenten
a pesadas regulaciones urbanísticas capaces
de frenar el desarrollo.
(De esta forma, cada zona especial podrá
especializarse en actividades diferentes u
organizarse de distinta manera para no solo
competir con el resto del mundo sino también
para competir entre sí, algo que obligaría
a sus administradores a copiar y mejorar las
mejores políticas existes para atraer inversión,
atraer talento y en definitiva impulsar el
desarrollo del país.)
¿Inteligente verdad?
Podemos imaginar centros financieros, centros
logísticos, zonas turísticas especiales
e incluso ciudades autónomas.
Un momento, ¿Ciudades autónomas?
Pues sí, habéis escuchado bien: ¿por qué
limitar estas zonas especiales solo a las
empresas? ¿Por qué no probar a construir
modelos de convivencia que puedan funcionar
mejor que el desastre que se vive hoy en Honduras?
Es lo que se conoce como “Free cities”,
de las que ya os adelanto hablaremos aquí
en VisualPolitik largo y tendido. Así que
no olvideis suscribiros y darle a la campanita
para estar al tanto de todos nuestros nuevos
vídeos.
Claro que, esperad un momento antes de lanzar
las campanas al vuelo.
Todo esto, amigos, puede parecernos un proyecto
muy, pero que muy atractivo pero, ¿no os
sorprende que sea precisamente la élite política
hondureña la que esté liderando este proceso?
¿No os genera alguna sospecha?
(El hermano del presidente hondureño, arrestado
en Miami. Está acusado de tráfico de drogas.
NYT)
Pues eso lo que en cierto modo piensa el propio
Paul Romer que ha tomado cierta distancia
de este proyecto. Bueno mejor dicho, ha escapado
corriendo ¿Por qué?
Pues porque tiene la impresión de que la
élite hondureña lo que realmente quiere
no es precisamente promover la competencia
y la inversión sino tener un territorio que
solo les favorezca a ellos.
(Han aprobado una nueva ley que cruza mi línea
roja. Esta ley elimina toda posibilidad de
responsabilidad electoral para las personas
que dirigen las zonas. Esto no estaba en la
ley que apoyé. [...]
No puedo decir si lo que estamos viendo es
una farsa o una tragedia. Podría terminar
siendo una farsa porque no puedo imaginar
que un inversionista reflexivo entraría e
invertiría en estas circunstancias, en un
lugar controlado por una aristocracia de amigos.
Paul romer)
Y no ha sido ni mucho menos el único.
La evolución que ha seguido este proyecto
genera muchas dudas, incluso existe la sosprecha
de que todas estas ZEDE terminarán siendo
simplemente un instrumento para que los oligarcas
de siempre se apoderen de más partes del
país y encima puedan hacer y deshacer a su
completo antojo.
Vamos, todo un refugio para narcos y oligarcas
de todo tipo.
La falta de transparencia y los conflictos
sociales causados no parecen reflejar la idea
de un gobierno que busca impulsar el desarrollo.
Por todo esto de la ilusión inicial se ha
pasado al desencanto y la sospecha.
Por así decirlo, estaríamos ante una idea
fantástica pero con una ejecución pésima
y unos objetivos aún peores.
Amigos el caso es que estas ZEDE están proyectadas
para arrancar a finales de 2019.
Claro, si consiguieran consolidarse y salir
adelante respetando el espíritu de libertad,
competencia e igualdad de oportunidades del
concepto de Zonas Económicas Especiales podríamos
estar ante un cambio de rumbo total para Honduras.
Pero, sí, es difícil ser optimistas este
caso.
En fin, la pregunta es, ¿Realmente Honduras
apostará y conseguirá sacar adelante un
modelo de ZEDEs plenamente autónomas sin
intromisión de los políticos? ¿Logrará
Honduras convertirse en la Shenzhen de centroamerica
o se convertirá en otro caso fallido como
la India?
Dejame tu respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta.
Si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no dejes de darle a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.